les Beatles et les Rolling Stones les
premiers sont depuis longtemps passés à
la postérité et les seconds roulent
toujours comme vient de nous le rappeler
à l'instant ce documentaire réalisé par
Christiane Ratinet et Michael Prazan
pourtant depuis des générations on
continue de les comparer de les opposer
nous allons en débattre maintenant avec
nos invités présents sur ce plateau de
débat doc aujourd'hui i Vigo pour
commencer bienvenue vous êtes
aujourd'hui le directeur général de TV5
Monde vous êtes journaliste critique
musicale avec un passage à Europain
notamment libération le magazine Rolling
Stones et spécialiste passionnés de pop
de rock votre dernier livre et une
édition augmentée de la biographie de
Michel Berger un ouvrage publié aux
éditions du Seuil avec nous également
Émilie Mazoyer bienvenue à vous vous
êtes vous aussi bien sûr une passionnée
de musique avec entre autres un passage
remarqué à la radio Le Mouv' Europe 1
vous présenter aujourd'hui sur France
Bleu entre 19h et 20h l'émission
quotidienne intitulée décibels c'est une
émission nationale donc sur le réseau de
France Bleu Bertrand Burgalat est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
à la fois producteur musicien
compositeur certain vous ont même
surnommé le film Spector français
pas très gentil pour fille Spector
j'espère
mon casier judiciaire merci c'est une
information vous avez travaillé sur près
de 210 que composés pour Marc Lavoine à
ranger le groupe Super grasse remixé
Depeche Mode et votre dernier album
s'intitule rêve capital il a été publié
en 2021 vous n'allez pas couper à la
question
Beatles ou Rolling Stones alors moi je
refuse toujours de répondre à cette
question pour une raison simple c'est
que quand on aime le rock on aime tout
le rock
en l'occurrence on parle de deux groupes
fondamentaux et en même temps très
différents l'un de l'autre alors qui
serait chart lui-même d'ailleurs vous
dirait c'est les Beatles qui ont ouvert
la voie c'est eux qui ont ouvert la
porte c'est eux qui ont ouvert la mairie
jusque là aucun artiste anglais n'avait
jamais connu le succès aux États-Unis
donc il y a d'abord eu les Beatles puis
il y a eu les Stones après ces deux
groupes différents les Beatles c'est un
groupe de rock n' roll les Stones c'est
un groupe de blues les formations sont
pas les mêmes les Beatles c'est trois
guitares une batterie les Stones au
départ il y a un piano en plus c'est du
Chicago Blues en fait ils n'ont
réellement en commun que Chuck Berry qui
vont jouer tous les deux c'est le point
de rencontre entre les deux alors
pardonnez-moi ubigo sur votre platine
personnelle est-ce qu'elles sont les
Beatles ou les Rolling Stones qui ont le
plus tourné même si vous le voulez pas
rentrer dans le petit jeu qui est le
meilleur entre bittles Rolling Stones
lequel avait le plus écouté sur votre
platine perso je suis incapable de vous
le dire mais je pense que je saurais
vous réciter quasi la totalité des
chansons des Beatles alors
qu'effectivement les Stones à partir du
début des années 80 c'est plus tellement
la peine on y reviendra peut-être
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure Beetle sur
Rolling Stones Stone c'est dur alors moi
aussi je bosse en touche souvent comme
Yves alors moi je réponds aujourd'hui
magnifique
je suis aussi assez d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit Yves Bigot sur le côté essayez
de les comparer musicalement c'est
dommage parce qu'ils sont vraiment très
très différents moi je vais plus aller
sur le plan personnel et je trouve les
Beatles beaucoup moins méchants que les
Stones moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à
pardonner au Rolling Stones on le voit
dans le documentaire ce qu'ils ont fait
à Brian Jones qui était quand même le
fondateur du groupe ils l'ont viré du
groupe en continuant à s'appeler les
Rolling Stones ils ont un peu voler son
bébé et le mec est mort trois semaines
après et ça moi voilà un petit peu de
mal donc
voilà donc je voterai Beatles
je trouve que la question est presque
hors sujet parce que j'ai trouvé ce
documentaire formidable attendez vous
allez d'abord vous allez voir ça
n'est pas un documentaire sur les
Beatles pour moi c'est un documentaire
passionnant ce qui m'étonne pas d'un des
auteurs Michael présent qui avait fait
un livre remarquable sur Pierre Goldman
et ça c'est un c'est un film sur
l'Angleterre de la guerre et de la
prière et à travers deux personnages qui
sont Brède Epstein et Andrew le goldam
et les deux sont fantastiques c'est on
se rend compte que dans les deux cas il
y a eu un entourage et d'ailleurs dès
que cet entourage dès que c'est manager
qui était honnête qui sont fait un petit
peu
avoir au départ mais qui ont très vite
ces groupes ont été entourés de gens
comme Alan Klein qui l'ont qui leur dit
vous faites avoir et les ont arnaqué
mais j'ai trouvé voilà que c'est ça dit
beaucoup de choses en particulier
parce qu'ils étaient quand j'ai commencé
à m'intéresser à musique au début des
années 70 c'était très connu et donc à
l'époque on pouvait pas écouter tout ce
qu'on voulait il fallait acheter des
disques et on avait tendance à chercher
autre chose donc ces disques là je les
connaissais parce que il passait à la
radio je connaissais pas tout donc je me
suis intéressé plutôt à Pink Floyd à
partir de Pink Floyd à d'autres choses
mais c'est plus tardivement et je trouve
les deux
passionnants mais moi des chansons que
je préfère des Stones sont pas leurs
chansons un peu blues c'est des choses
comme you can't always get what you want
to c'est pas Charlie wats le pauvre qui
joue d'ailleurs cette producteur et même
certains trucs récents comme
que que j'aime beaucoup
produits par Christine c'est donc je
suis pas un intégriste des Stones bon
j'ai un début de réponse j'ai même une
réponse merci j'aime beaucoup
qui parle de cette confrontation entre
les deux groupes
évidemment vous avez commencé à répondre
tout à l'heure à la question que je
voulais vous poser mais néanmoins il y a
une chose qui est sûre au travers des
chiffres et ne serait-ce que la
chronologie des deux groupes les Beatles
sont toujours eu un temps d'avance sur
les Stones ça c'est un discutable à vos
yeux
les Beatles sont offerts à loin le Be
Your Man donc composition de Léna des
McCartney au Rolling Stones ça pouvait
pas être dans l'autre sens
ces deux groupes formidablesment
différents mais qui comme la très bien
dit Bertrand et comme le monde très bien
le film voilà viennent de la même époque
c'est des enfants de la guerre c'est des
enfants de la reconstruction de
l'Angleterre qui a été
totalement détruite par le Blitz très
très dans une Angleterre très très
pauvre où on n'avait pas de
l'électricité toute la journée on
n'avait pas nécessairement tout le temps
de courant tout il faisait froid
et qui ont explosé au début des années
60 en même temps que l'Angleterre en
fait ils ont fait passer
l'Angleterre et on peut dire le monde
derrière eux du noir et blanc à la
couleur des années 60 et puis alors avec
1966 en plus alors non seulement un été
le plus bel été sans doute de l'histoire
de la vieille Albion et puis la victoire
en Coupe du monde à Wembley donc c'était
le Pinnacle du Swinging London et le
Swinging London c'est quoi
c'est les Beatles c'est les Stones et
c'est les filles en mini-jupe les vrais
rebelles dans l'histoire c'est quand
même les Beatles alors oui
contrairement à on le voit dans
l'épisode marketing qui suivra et on y
reviendra on le voit bien dans l'extrait
qu'on vient de voir à quel point Mick
Jagger et à l'aise il a des lettres il a
fait des études il est redoutablement
intelligent malins manif très très bien
ça il fait un petit regard caméra il dit
qu'il est diplomates et tout Amic Jagger
illustré jamais arrivé ce qui est arrivé
à Lennon et dont on parle dans le
documentaire ça phrase malheureuse et
hors contexte sur les Beatles sont plus
célèbres que Jésus et qui a fait
beaucoup de mal au Beatles notamment aux
Etats-Unis et donc oui ils viennent du
pas de la même époque du même pays mais
pas du même milieu et de ça ils partent
vraiment pas du même endroit c'est aussi
moi pour ça que souvent j'ai une petite
tendresse supplémentaire pour pour les
Beatles mais quel bonheur voilà Jagger
il est tellement à l'aise il est en
brillant fils de professeur d'éducation
physique
alors que évidemment les Beatles c'est
Liverpool c'est un accent à couper au
couteau et ce sont des jeunes qui ont
tourné déjà depuis un moment avant de
connaître le succès et bel et bien en
blouson noir et dans des dans des boîtes
notamment en Bourbourg ou s'agissait de
faire X7 par soirée c'était terriblement
épuisant sa Suisse c'est l'histoire des
Beatles et de dormir sur des bancs la
nuit sans chauffage en pouvant pas se
laver et au milieu des en fait du
quartier où était la reperban quartier
célèbre je regarde les chiffres Bertrand
burgalla évidemment la culture la
musique n'aime pas beaucoup les chiffres
et c'est pas évident pas le seul critère
mais enfin tout de même Beatles 12
albums en 6 ans 12 albums en 6 ans les
Stones c'est alors ça dépend des sources
c'est un 23 albums en Grande-Bretagne 25
albums US en 60 ans de carrière là il y
a pas photo les Beatles sont vendus 1
milliard de disques au bas mot les St
allez on va dire entre 200 000 et 250
000 les Beatles seront vendus auraient
vendus 5 fois plus de disques que les
Stones avec 6 ans de carrière seulement
alors vu au vu de ces chiffres on se dit
il y a pas photo tout de même et Émilie
posait une bonne question tout à l'heure
c'est que c'est assez beau de se dire
pourquoi eux à un moment et pas d'autres
parce que sur la ligne de départ des
groupes formidables 250 millions à
l'Égypte pardon en Angleterre aux
États-Unis sur la ligne de départ il y
avait des musiciens extraordinaires et
il y en a pourquoi ça a été ce groupe là
pourquoi ça pas été les Kings etc je
pense qu'il y a il y a le hasard il y a
tout un contexte humain et quand je
parlais quand on regarde simplement les
Beatles ils avaient un producteur
formidable
George Martin ils avaient un manager qui
qui est un portrait et on le voit en
filigrane de l'Angleterre mais aussi de
ce qui s'est de
[Musique]
c'est que enfin il y a lui un désir de
de lui cherche au contraire une forme de
non pas d'en bourgeoisement mais c'est
aussi ce qui est arrivé à beaucoup de
gens d'origine juive en Angleterre après
la guerre qui voulait absolument même
changer leur nom etc et donc on sent
toutes ces questions là chez Brian
Einstein et Andrew golden que je connais
bien qui est un ami il a évidemment joué
très intelligemment le contre-emploi et
et Andrew par exemple l'histoire qu'on
voit dans le dans le documentaire
laisserez-vous votre fille sortez avec
un Rolling Stones c'est pas du tout lui
qui a initié ça en revanche cet article
du mélodie Maker il en a il a pris des
publicités avec ça mais il y avait
vraiment une vraie sympathie une vraie
il y avait une compétition fraternelle
entre les Beatles et Stone comme il y a
une compétition entre mon équivalent
américain d'après vous office Hector et
les Beach Boys c'est-à-dire des gens qui
étaient à la fois en compétition
mais d'une façon très très amicale il y
avait une émulation et chacun entend
voilà ils entendaient un truc ils
disaient qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour
faire mieux et ça c'est prodigieux mais
c'est un moment quand même de grâce
totale et puis après ça se dérègle
justement ben Epstein meurt il y a plein
de choses comme ça qui font que c'est
pas la même chose et si on prend une
jaune ça en revanche alors je suis
totalement agnostique mais on ne le
leader historique mais on a l'impression
quand même que
tous sont d'accord justement parce que
les les livres de d'andrologoldam qui
est un écrivain prodigieux sa musique
Angleterre tout ce qu'il écrit il m'a
fait plein de notes de pochettes pour
nos disques qui sont formidables mais on
sent qu'ils sont tous d'accord pour dire
que le pauvre Bryan Jones qui était
effectivement le moteur au bout d'un
moment suivez plus et leur casser les
pieds quoi et parce qu'ils se sont
révélés les deux autres Jagger Richard
qui composait pas au départ et donc il y
a eu une espèce de dynamique qui a été
différente et parce que je finis
là-dessus parce que les Stones s'ils ont
aussi comment c'est quelque chose qui
est pas forcément avec eux ils ont fait
beaucoup de mal les Stones sur une chose
c'est qu'ils ont installé tout ce cliché
de la bohème rock et qui a fini moi
quand j'ai commencé à produire des
disques la moitié des musiciens a été
nomade parce qu'il voyait qu'il serait
charts et qui maintenait toujours le
doute on savait pas et il s'avère cool
donc il y a eu beaucoup de morts à cause
des Stones et vous évoquez
manager des Stones avec qui vous êtes
toujours en contact hein il est toujours
vivant une partie des Beatles c'est une
partie des Stones Hugo cette concurrence
cette scène concurrence cette émulation
entre les deux cette amitié aussi qu'on
découvre évidemment et vous l'avez
précisé tout à l'heure entre les deux
groupes et entre certaines personnes
ils vous en ont parlé à posteriori
surtout après la fin des Beatles les uns
ou les autres
c'était pas un sujet pour eux c'est pas
un sujet majeur d'abord et après il y a
une si vous voulez personne n'a été les
Beatles avant les Beatles personne n'a
été les Stones avant les Stones donc de
toute façon c'est comme la c'est comme
pour Johnny Hallyday en France on se
moque de lui mais qui a été Johnny
Hallyday c'était où le il y avait pas la
Bible sur ce qu'il fallait faire donc
c'est des gens qui ont découvert un
univers un mode de vie qu'ils ont créé
qu'ils ont inventé en marchant et en
faisant des erreurs évidemment mais donc
ça ça vous soude c'est comme quand on a
fait alors ça n'existe plus aujourd'hui
heureusement quand on faisait le service
militaire ensemble ça fait voilà ça fait
des copains ils ont vécu les mêmes ils
ont vécu les mêmes expériences puis ils
sont de la même génération
ils sont pas exactement du même milieu
mais ils ont vécu les mêmes choses et
puis surtout ils ont subi les mêmes
choses après aussi pour aller peut-être
jusqu'au bout parce que lorsque vous
dites ils ont subi les mêmes choses
peut-être le délire de ce qui a été la
Beatlemania alors qui était plus forte
pour les Beatles ce que pour les Stone
mais ce délire cette pression incroyable
des des fans qui veulent vous arracher
vos cheveux qui qui menaçaient de faire
écrouler le toit de votre voiture quand
vous étiez dedans parce qu'ils montaient
dessus le délire absolu le fait danger
hein
ils ont connu un peu l'équivalent dans
leur première tournée américaine comme
ça où ils ont eu des épisodes hyper
violents quand même le help de duo
magique McCartney Lennon c'était déjà un
appel au secours
ce compte tenu de cette notoriété non je
pense que ça help pour le coup c'est
vraiment un appel métaphysique personnel
intime de John Lennon Christin dans ma
période où j'étais le gros John c'est il
avait voilà il avait il avait grossi il
était voilà il était pas à l'aise avec
cette notoriété c'est quelqu'un qui
venait alors même si des quatre Beatles
c'était celui qui était de la toute
petite bourgeoisie là où les autres
étaient vraiment des des fils d'ouvriers
mais il a eu cette période et elle comme
ça c'est un cri au secours c'est un jeu
c'est je voudrais être vrai je voudrais
retrouver les raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai fait ça avec les trois autres à un
moment où il perdait le contrôle help ça
a été le single le plus vendu un des
Beatles bon ils ont spirituels les
Beatles les Stones vous êtes d'une
génération un petit peu différente de
nos deux autres invités avec un recul
différent une approche différente
qu'elle soit musicale show business vous
inspirez qui quoi essentiellement les
Stones c'est les Beatles
elle est vertigineuse elle est
vertigineuse parce que beaucoup très peu
de gens
osent s'en réclamer tout le monde adore
les Stones et les Beatles mais personne
dit ah oui c'est mon inspiration
principale parce qu'on sent bien que
pas du tout alors je ne crois pas
pour le coup alors les Beatles ont eu la
chance entre guillemets de s'arrêter
avant de faire un mauvais disque enfin
en ce qui me concerne en tout cas je
trouve qu'il y a pas grand chose à
acheter dans la discographie des Beatles
quand on va se pencher sur les albums
des Stones certains albums des années
80-90 il y a forcément des trucs un peu
en dessous parce que à certains moments
ils ont tenté d'être à la mode ou de
suivre voilà certaines certaines vogues
on va dire musicale mais je pense que
pour le coup dans les années 60 ils ont
tellement tout inventé inspirer tout le
monde je sais plus qui parlait des Beach
Boys tout à l'heure je crois que c'est
toi Bertrand bon bah quand les Beatles
se font Sergent Pepper les Beach Boys
enfin non c'est l'inverse
revolver ou Robert Souls et ils se
disent il faut qu'on fasse mieux Brian
Wilson fait petshows qui est détesté par
le groupe et la maison de disque mais ma
carte née entend ça ils disent on va
faire mieux on va faire mieux mais pour
moi alors on va pas rentrer
dans l'exégèse mais je trouve que dans
l'influence ce qu'il faut dire aussi et
je pense a été leur force c'est qu'ils
ont d'abord été menus par l'admiration
l'admiration des bluesmenes dans le cas
des Stones s'admiration de Chuck Berry
des dico crâne et pour moi c'est très
important pour faire aujourd'hui encore
on voit souvent et c'est ce que tu
disais Émilie on voit des gens qui
disent on voit très bien ce qu'ils ont
écouté c'est normal
chacun quand on va commencer à faire de
la musique on part pas de zéro mais
cette admiration aujourd'hui elle a
souvent tendance à être cachée donc les
artistes vont citer des artistes qui
font bien ils vont dire Velvet
Underground des trucs mais leur vrais
admirations il les cache et il tourne en
rond parce que toutes les époques de la
musique ça a été eux ça a été ça les
groupes comme les spécial c'était de ce
cas ils ne masquez pas et c'est ça qui
leur faisait qui les faisait avancer
parce que à partir du moment
on avoue sa reconnaissance pour les
certaines choses on s'en affranchit
autrement c'est comme quand à l'école on
copie sur le voisin on peut pas faire
quelque chose de très original quand on
copie servilement je veux poursuivre ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure ils ne
sont pas has been aujourd'hui autrement
dit dans des sipel votre émission on a
le droit des Stones on a le droit au
Beatles aujourd'hui les auditeurs aiment
vous le font savoir oui ça reste quand
même des groupes majeurs et en plus
c'est intéressant parce que donc moi
travaillant pour France Bleu qui est une
radio qui diffuse une énorme majorité de
titres en français
voilà ça passe dans l'oreille comme si
c'était en français les Stones et les
Beatles vraiment il y a des il y a des
standards des classiques qui font que ça
va pas rebuter les les auditeurs
clairement pas après encore une fois en
ce qui concerne les Stones c'est un peu
comme quand on va les voir en concert on
veut pas le nouvel album
on veut on veut les classiques on veut
satisfaction on veut celle dont tu
parlais ou quand al with get what you
want on veut les chansons qu'on connaît
par cœur voilà donc ce sont des chansons
qui émergents sont les grands titres des
Stones avec les formidables albums
Bigard menteurs
ça ça arrive après la fin des Stones des
Beatles quasiment là on voit cette
montée en puissance des Stones qui
arrive finalement alors que l'immeuble
se sépare c'est-à-dire que les Stones
surtout ils ont connu le développement
de la musique live
les Beatles quand ils tournaient donc
jusqu'à fin août 1966 avec des petits
amplis pourris ils sont dans des même
pas jouer tellement tellement oui voilà
les fans hurlaient etc alors que les
Stones sont connus le développement des
concerts des tournées faramineuses dans
les stades avec leur avion pour aller de
ville en ville etc donc c'est là qu'ils
ont connu une carrière qui pour le coup
est différente de celle des Beatles et
on caricaturé jadis en disant les
Beatles c'est les albums les Stones
c'est les concerts et c'est évidemment
comme toute caricature c'est faux mais
ça n'est pas complètement non
c'est quand on voit des films comme Gimi
Shelter on se rend compte que des années
60 ces groupes là vivaient comme on vit
aujourd'hui c'est il prenait l'avion
comme
aujourd'hui il y a des paris Rodez en
avion ça paraissait aberrant mais bon ça
on parait c'est un autre sujet mais ils
avaient internet c'était le télex
ils avaient envoyé ils avaient des
répondeurs enfin ils avaient accès à des
choses et téléphone de voiture donc ils
vivaient et ils ont installé aussi le
mode de vie actuel c'est à dire le côté
des drogues récréatifs une forme de
dédonisme alors qu'en réalité il bossait
comme des chiens ils n'ont jamais arrêté
12 albums aussi mythiques
j'avais un livre que les Anglais avaient
fait comme ils peuvent le faire le côté
très hauteur jour par jour en studio
tel instrument était utilisé et on se
rend compte mais il n'arrêtait pas ah
bah ils ont pris deux fois des vacances
de la série de concerts que les Beatles
ont fait à Paris une quarantaine de
concerts à l'Olympe voilà et
l'après-midi ils étaient à
Boulogne-Billancourt en studio ils
enregistré des trucs
ça leur a pas apporté chance c'est là
qu'ils ont pris les mauvaises décisions
pour Apple je pense
allez un autre extrait du documentaire
cette voie pour parler de l'engagement
politique de l'un et l'autre groupe
les gamins envoyés au Vietnam pour se
battre écoutez les Stones pour
s'extraire de cette horrible guerre
mais aussi parce que la violence de leur
musique reflétait la dureté du conflit
[Musique]
John Lennon m'a dit plus tard avec les
autres on aurait voulu se joindre
manifestations
mais Brian Epstein notre manager nous a
dit si vous participez à ces
manifestations anti-américaines nous
serons interdits de territoire aux
États-Unis et on va perdre beaucoup
d'argent
alors comme quoi le business le
show-business a peut-être récupéré ces
deux groupes à un moment de leur
carrière a fait évoluer leur carrière
également c'est aussi votre analyse ou
non moi je pense pas c'est l'inverse
c'est eux qui ont fait
évoluer qu'on révolutionné la société et
d'une certaine façon c'est eux qui ont
inventé cette industrie on la rendant
planétaire et surtout en la rendant
aussi incroyablement profitable parce
que avant eux c'était de la petite
boutique c'était des petits labels
souvent locaux
etc donc non le et au contraire
justement le l'engagement alors
politique et culturel parce que c'est
une révolution culturelle en fait le
rock et les Beatles les Stones et Dylan
et les autres
évidemment c'est d'un seul coup d'abord
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est la jeunesse qui impose
sa culture à l'ensemble de la société ça
n'était jamais pourquoi c'est possible
parce qu'elle a le pouvoir d'achat parce
qu'elle a la culture et puis parce
qu'elle a la dispose à sa disposition
cette culture justement qui parle à tout
le monde et où il n'y a pas besoin
justement d'avoir fait des études pour y
accéder donc c'est vraiment eux qui ont
changé le monde sur l'engagement John
Lennon était très engagé il a montré
d'ailleurs après la séparation des
Beatles puisqu'il a mis des années une
fois qu'il est parti aux États-Unis pour
avoir la fameuse Green Card parce que
c'était John le Rouge
il était voilà on voulait pas lui donner
la bonne carte
il a été assassiné mais c'est pas ce qui
est à mon avis c'est pas ce qu'il avait
fait de mieux parce que d'abord la
guerre du Vietnam c'est plus complexe
elle a été déclenchée par Kennedy un
démocrate et elle a été arrêtée par
républicain Nixon qui était lui un vrai
fils de prolétaire comme donc c'est un
peu plus complexe Nord Vietnam et c'est
pas tout à fait des démocrates chrétiens
c'était quand même des staliniens donc
la guerre du Vietnam c'était la
conscription le problème dans la dans la
jeunesse américaine c'est cette guerre
mais dans le cas de Jagger il y avait un
côté récup quand il fait Street fighting
man il y a ce côté
quand il s'est un peu quand on l'entend
dire à Brothers à
altermont quand il est quand il essaie
de jouer comme ça ce côté et un côté
acteur quand même et je trouve que ce
truc de la guerre du Vietnam et un peu
trop
présent et dans le cas de Lennon il
s'est un peu aussi perdu avec ses
bedines avec Yoko etc au tout début des
années 70 après évidemment la séparation
des des Beatles l'engagement politique
des uns et des autres on a c'est vrai
souvent reproché au Beatles de ne sais
pas être assez souvent engagé
politiquement
l'image qui reste aujourd'hui c'est vrai
Beatles Peace and Love et plutôt Rolling
Stones underground et plus
il faut faire attention aux visions
françaises et idéologique parce que là
on parle de citoyens britanniques qui
vivent aux États-Unis et qui ont un
succès planétaire parce que en fait ce
qu'il faut bien voir dans la valeur
foncière
révolutionnaire et rebelle du Roc c'est
que il faut intégrer que toutes choses
qui exalte la vie
combat
les choses qui qui vont contre la vie
donc il n'y a pas besoin de dire
halte à la guerre au Vietnam ou voter
machin ou saucisses là pour en fait être
véritablement engagé dans justement tout
ce qui porte la vie et qui combat les
les forces anti-vie alors bon c'est vrai
c'est pas non plus votre période mais
maintenant avec le recul les images des
Beatles du Stone aujourd'hui
la photo de
Jagger en manif je me dis ouais à la
fois ça lui coûte pas très cher c'est ce
que disait tout à l'heure il y a un côté
vraiment
je compare aussi avec la France ou par
exemple pareil on met 68 Jacques Dutronc
on sait pas où il était il y a plein de
gens comme ça qui était pas là qui sont
pas allés ce qui est marrant Émilie
c'est que les Beatles c'est parce que
c'est des actes qui comptent oui Beatles
ils font taxman dès qu'ils ont dès qu'il
faut payer des impôts et les Stones
soi-disant plus à gauche ils vont
enregistrer en France parce que le
gouvernement travailleuse de Cannes
imposer les grandes fortunes comme eux à
98% donc ils ont fait de l'évasion
fiscale chez nous ils ont d'abord disons
pour des raisons fiscales et peut-être
aussi pour la French Connection pour la
qualité du produit à la fin des années
70 à la fin des années 60 pardon dans la
pratique
il me semble plus près de enfin
[Musique]
là moi pour le coup à l'époque je me
souviens j'étais ado et j'avais trouvé
ça un petit peu pathétique en fait donc
je pense que déjà entre les années 60 et
les années 90 on était beaucoup moins
innocents et nous le public et eux les
artistes et que finalement les Stones et
les Beatles eux ils ont peut-être un
petit peu subi cette histoire là sans
vraiment comprendre ce qui était en
train de se jouer Blur et oasis il
savait parfaitement ce qui était en
train de se jouer ils ont joué avec un
petit moment puis après ils ont jeté le
et puis aussi la différence majeure
c'est que Blur et oasis c'est resté un
phénomène purement britannique pas du
tout de traduction aux États-Unis donc
on n'est pas dans un phénomène mondial
et du coup on pèse sur la société
britannique ça c'est sûr mais pas sur la
société mondiale c'est une réponse aussi
la brique pop c'était une réponse au
grunge qui était américain et donc ils
ont inventé ça toute pièce avec Nirvana
de oasis qui était un groupe sans inter
enfin assez scolaire mais qui a dit
c'est magnifique il a dit 100 fois c'est
le plus grand groupe de rock du monde et
à la fin il y a eu des gens qui il y a
des gens qui l'ont creux ça c'est
merveilleux quand même bon on attend
toujours la dernière pépite et on nous
annonce deux pépites c'est parce que
vous en pensez la première ça serait pas
de ma carte mec qui jouerait de la base
sur un titre des Rolling Stones à venir
et peut-être et peut-être une costard à
la batterie première chose il a il a
démenti donc c'est que ma carte nez à la
base
bien sûr c'est les gens vont acheter
l'album uniquement pour ça et alors
deuxième promesse cette fois du côté des
Beatles un nouveau titre inédit grâce
l'intelligence artificielle qui qui
referait vivre la voie de Lennon one
more time une fois encore parce que j'ai
eu deux titres qu'on a fait revivre
cette voie de Lennon on a déjà eu
récemment les billes les Beatles qui
ressentaient sur le playback de
goldenlynose des Beach Boys bon on a ça
si c'est ça artificielle on est
tranquille pour un petit moment quand
même pour être en continu à chanter là
c'est validé par ma carte mec quand même
c'est une vieille bande il y a la voix
de Lennon mais il y a une musique qui
n'arrange pas à ma carte n'est donc en
fait l'intelligence artificielle a servi
à récupérer juste la voix de Lennon mais
j'ai un tout petit peu d'espoir en
disant
toujours faire des choses c'est de toute
façon ça a toujours été le moteur du
groupe c'est celui qui voulait toujours
aller de l'avant toujours ce qui se
passe des choses etc donc c'est normal
mais ce morceau il l'avait essayé au
moment de l'anthologie de 95 vous avez
fait deux morceaux de Lennon et George
Harrison avait dit ce morceau là il est
pourri moi je veux pas entendre parler
et le moment on va le citer ça sera
vraiment le mot de la fin je crois que
c'est un morceau qui date de 78 c'est un
morceau qui s'appelle narwenden en tous
les mcartait a fait un morceau avec
Kanye West donc il y a déjà vis de
consentement
c'est la fin de cette émission on aurait
passé bien plus de temps avec vous pour
parler des Stones et un grand merci
vraiment à tous les trois les réactions
sur hashtag debadoc sur Twitter alors là
mon avis on va y avoir le droit et
j'espère vous serez là pour réagir parce
que ce qu'on sait ces réactions merci à
sel massalik comme à la coutumé MA aider
à préparer cette émission et moi je vous
donne rendez-vous pour un prochain débat
docks ça sera bien entendu avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]